hello YouTube just la mesilla friends
this is grunge in here and today I'm
going to show you a trap exist in
Budapest gambit for the white now I must
admit that when first time I made the
system even I fall into this trap and
even my own rating is 2000 plus on both
just calm and jazz cube calm and even if
your trap doesn't work you can come out
as a very good position for white so
let's see how we can trick our opponent
and put up his gambit
now the war is are very much familiar so
why it start with a d4 and black
responds with the knight f6 and after c4
here comes the budapest gambit start
with the move e5 now here white has many
options and there are many openings
against the booth abyss chemists but my
simple recommendation over here is just
take the pawn and now here there are few
moves for the black but the most general
response of the budapest gambit here
gambit here will be Knight to g4 so now
black wants to regain the pawn now here
the system I am recommending at the
starting point it looks like we are
defending the pawn but the whole idea of
the white is to carry on the development
with the protecting of the pawns so here
please note there are two moves over
here one is Knight to f3 and Bishop to
f4 but I am recommending here then you
play Bishop to f4
because the problem with the Knight f3
move is black can play this book which
is Bishop to c5 and now you can see the
both the PCs are attacking the f2 Square
and white has to forcefully play this
move which is III and what it leads is a
bishop will be very passive so that's
why it's very important at this point
you play Bishop f4 first so here we we
are defending the pawn and the general
theory of the Budapest raised Knight
goes to c6 so again attacking the pawn
and now we are going to play Knight f3
so again we are defending the pawn now
as for the theory always the bishop
comes into the picture so bishop check
and now White has a two options here my
recommendation is you play Knight to d2
and after Queen to e7 so now you can see
the three pcs are attacking that pawn
the main theory of the white side start
with the move a3 now here I'm not
recommending this move because there are
a few reasons first reason is there is a
nasty trap exist and especially if you
do not know about this trap there are
likely to be chances are there that you
are going to fall into this trap so this
is a very famous trap let me show you
that trap so here black has a very
cunning reply which is Knight takes e5
and if white greedily take the bishop so
a cross before
and black has this stunning reply which
is Knight to d3 checkmate you can see
this pawn is right now pin and the white
king does not have any squares so this
is a very famous trap and even though
let's say even why does not fall for
this trap so for example if the white
plays moves such as Knight cross e5
Knight cross ePHI and III so now you can
see this white Bishop is guarding the
critical d3 square so that leads to the
force variation that black has to
capture the night but after Bishop
captures Queen captures and d6 by black
white has a very slight advantage and
the reason is it's okay that white has a
bishop pair but black does not have any
weaknesses and there is a big theory on
the Budapest and how you can play on
with this black position and many people
have one good games so that's why this
system I personally don't think so it's
a give you a good advantage as a white
so what my own recommendation is after
Queen to e7 instead of a three you play
this move which is III
so of course that allows black to regain
the pole so Knight takes e5 Here I am
recommending that first you exchange one
pair of night
so you exchange one night and then you
play Bishop to e2 now the main theory
section of the Budapest goes like this
so black generally castle over here and
white do the same so white will castle
and now to open up the diagonals for
this Bishop black general plays d6 so
it's not only opening up the diagonal
for the bishop but it's also protecting
the knight
and here come star mu which is Knight to
b3
now White has a very very cunning idea
right now first sight it looks like
White has weakened this c4 square and as
per the normal theory of the Budapest
black always play this move which is
Bishop to e6 and it looks very logical
because to PC is now attacking the pawn
and why it needs to defend somehow this
point but no it's not case here comes a
very cute trap I give you a few seconds
can you find amazing more here ok the
move is a three now you can see that
Bishop cannot go to e5 because white
will simply capture with the night so
the only logical square for the Bishop
is it goes to c5 but now you can see
these two pcs are protected by this d6
pawn so now d6 pawn has been overloaded
and now white will simply a piece up
with this cunning move which is Knight
takes e5 now you can see if black does
not recapture the piece then like will
be simply a piece now and even if black
capture denied now this Knight support
has been gone so white will simply
capture this Knight and what will emerge
with a piece up
so this is a very cute wrap exist in the
Budapest and as I said it's not only
trappy line you can play as a weapon for
a while because even though let's say
your opponent does not fall into this
trap
he will waste a quiet amount of time and
that will help you and specially blitz
in the bullet games and at the end of
the whole thing
at least white will have a superior
position I hope you learn and enjoy this
trap feel free to comment on my video
and I'll meet you soon bye